嗨 大家好 我是马克洋
今天來跟大家做一個實戰復盤
講一下我前幾天的一筆隔日沖交易
那這筆單是一單一天賺了54萬
那有些人想要知道我這筆單的操作一些想法
所以今天來跟大家分享一下
然後我來跟大家做一個前情提要
就是這筆單是3月15到3月16的長榮的隔日沖
那在前一天3月15的長榮是跌得非常慘的
從高點的167到最後是收在158
是跌了9塊
那是算是一個大跌啦
那在這一天我是有在這邊164.5先跑掉
就是這個我之後再拍影片講解前一天的操作吧
那反正我在後面它跌到下面
又收繳收回來160的地方
這個尾盤的地方我又重新接回了我的30口長榮
那30口就是等同於60張的長榮
大概是市值1000萬的一個部位
然後我在尾盤把它買回來的其中一個原因是
3月15號的下午是長榮的法縮會
那法縮會是一個非常關鍵的一個事件啦
是非常會影響股價的一個事件
那我當時以長榮的財報來看
我當時是預期長榮會公佈一年賺45塊到50塊
甚至有可能到50塊
然後股力的話我認為會發25塊到30塊
當然當時我內心是很樂觀的
我覺得有可能如果它的營收再增加的話
會賺到50塊然後發到接近30塊
是有可能的
那所以我當天就是尾盤又接回來
那如果這個公佈營收很好
股力也很高的話
這個第二天股價很可能會衝上去
那當然是因為有一部分是我消息也沒那麼零通嘛
那個我看PET上面
那天下午3月15下午我是去申宏的交易室
然後跟他們討論交易策略
然後順便也看一下長榮發說會
欸結果在那個公佈就是發18塊
然後減資然後再加6塊的時候
就PET上就已經有人說是18加6了
真的超扯的
所以這個台灣還是
還是有很多這個內褲線啊
什麼消息很零通的這些事情
那可能也可以解釋
捐一天這個大跌吧
那反正這個沒事
反正反正那天就是公佈出來是18加6嘛
等同是發了24塊
那我認為是有點不符合我的預期的
而且也不知道市場當天這個就是第二天對於肢減這件事情的看法
然後我當時是有做好就是第二天如果開盤的時候我會看當充的一些日內波指標
那如果不符合預期的話我就會馬上把我的30口布會除掉
然後到了第二天
第二天早上發生的事情是從八點半撮合
我不確定是不是八點半就漲停了
就是在試撮的時候長榮的現貨就一直亮紅燈就是漲停
但是因為試撮就是你委託量超級大
委託額度超級大的大戶
本來就可以在那邊玩燈
可以在那邊鎖漲停
所以其實那個可能意義沒有到很大
但是就是一直到了八點四十三分的時候
期貨的撮合都還是一直在一百六十九
哇那這個就是很嚇人的一件事情
因為八點四十五常期貨就會開盤
然後到八點四十三分就不能夠抽單了
就是說期貨的開盤前最後兩分鐘是不能抽單的
現貨才可以
那這個也是非常合理的
因為如果期貨不能抽單
然後現貨開盤前兩分鐘也不能抽單的話
那如果在期貨的最後兩分鐘
就發生一個崩跌
那你掛的買單現貨的買單還不能夠賣掉
那這樣就不太合理
這個你都已經看到崩跌了
然後你掛那個買單還不能抽單
所以期貨不能抽單
雖然現貨可以抽單這個其實是合理的啦
然後八點四十三的時候
都還在一六九
所以我就馬上掛了這個賣單
就是要把我三十口不回全部賣掉
因為我認為一六九是一個價格不合理的地方
那其實就是我們交易就是在交易
短線交易就是交易這些不合理
那台子騎啊 姑騎啊
其實也都是這樣
就是你看市場裡面有什麼不合理的地方去交易它
尤其是我做的很多策略都是跟撮合這件事情有關
就是你去預測撮合比較有可能合理在什麼價位
然後後來出現在什麼價位
其實我前不久
也不是前蠻久
那就是去年我做的那個航運的五分盤
其實也是類似這樣子
就是跟撮合有關的一個策略
那這算是台股的一個特性吧
我覺得也算是一種遊戲的漏洞
就是撮合這件事情
那有點扯遠
反正就是講一下我交易的想法
然後
因為
它的前高是在171
然後昨天的高點
是在167
所以在170附近是有很大的壓力的
就是
昨天的高點是167嘛
所以這一段是
從138漲上來挑戰170
又在170附近遇到壓力
然後在前面的這個高點也是
這個到171的時候又掉下來
那
你們去看日線圖就是
前高就是171
然後這邊到167
所以170附近是有
就是一個
這個
暫時無法突破的壓力
那所以
要直接開到169
我認為是
幾乎不可能
就是現貨
現貨要開到169
我認為很難
然後
當然
這一個
我不確定是單一的大戶
還是
是一個
群組的大
很多大戶的群組
就是
他們當天
白天
早上開盤想要做的事情
就是
他們希望
開盤
長榮就會接近漲停
然後
他們現貨掛那樣的意思就是
最好開在169
然後就直接衝上去
當天掌停是172.5
然後就
一路開盤
沒多久就
鎖死掌停
然後大家都追進去嘛
然後就掌停
鎖死
那
他們可能
有非常多的長榮現貨
有可能
如果能夠突破170
然後第二天再跳高上去的話
那可能
就
往上就萬里無雲
甚至
就是
要再往上飆到接近200
是有可能的
所以
他們想要用這種
比較激烈的方式
直接突破170
這邊的
壓力
但是我認為
是
當天我是覺得
幾乎
不太能夠成功
就是
成功的機率很低啦
因為
其實前一天
我認為
資檢
不太確定
對市場的
想法是什麼
然後
發
18+6
發24塊
其實
跟陽明發的差不多
就陽明前幾天
就已經公佈了
然後長榮的股價
是
然後
陽明那天的收盤價是
所以會有一個比價效應
就是
長榮可能會跌
然後陽明會漲上來
因為他們發的股力差不多
但是
股價卻差到
30塊
所以
要直接讓長榮
開到快要漲停
然後
就是
開盤
就去衝漲停
我當時認為
非常不合理
所以我在
8.43到8.50之間
我就馬上掛出了
這個
賣單
而且是把我
手上全部的長榮起步
也全部都賣掉
那我昨天是買在
這個
然後就
開盤直接賣在
這個
我的單都是有
有
貼在
我的FB
就是那個禮拜我想說
我做一個挑戰
就是我每天都
PO我當天
做
隔日沖策略的對賬單
然後
就是
我占一個禮拜
能不能夠
靠隔日沖
賺到超過
100萬
那
這影片好像有點長
我下個影片再講
我這
隔日沖
這五天
每一天的
操作的一些想法
好了
然後
反正就是
3月16
早上9點多
我就PO
這單賺了
54萬
然後
反正就是
43分
還沒有抽單
我就
在169
把我的30口全部都出掉了
然後
這邊我也
順便講一個
我很常跟大家
重複這個
講的
就是
這個也跟
行為經濟學有關
就是
市場是錯的
很多人都說
市場是對的嘛
但是
其實市場上
組合的
就是
全部的人
然後
每一個人
都有人性
那
大家的人性
都會
一起犯
一樣的錯誤
就是
非常非常多的錯誤
就是我
常在行為經濟學
都會講到那些錯誤
所以市場上
常常會充滿
無效率的定價
然後
特殊規則
也都會有
規則的漏洞
所以
這個也算是
這個
我抓到了一個
市場的無效率定價
然後
賺到了一筆吧
在當天
長榮暴跌是
從169
一路跌到150
然後
陽明還是
維持在130
沒有跌
所以
就是
也符合我原本說的
這個
比價效應吧
他們
長榮跟陽明發的差不多
那
沒道理長榮比陽明貴那麼多
然後
也順便講一個
我自己沒有在用
但是可能可行的策略
就是
長榮跟陽明的股價
通常都很接近
然後
有時候互相超扯
如果
他們的
這個
股價大到
價差大到
你覺得不合理的地步
例如說
當天的
接近30塊
甚至30塊
反正30塊左右
那你可能就可以
空長榮
然後
多陽明
在價差10塊的時候平掉
類似這樣子
就是
這個算是一個
比較穩
就是
可以小賺一點
但是
需要的總資金也會比較多
所以
我自己是沒有執行這個策略
但是
是有想過
這樣的策略是可行的
好
那
這個
大概就是
我當時
這筆單
這個
進場跟出場的一些想法跟邏輯
哦
然後
很多新聞說
什麼
那個
當
因為當天
這個
大家應該知道
當天後來的行情是崩跌
後來
這個
就從
一路跌到了
跌停
就是
跌到了
142.5
呃
就是
有碰到跌停價
第二天
有碰到跌停
在哪邊呢
這邊
反正就是第二天
是
是有
最低點是有到跌停
那
就有
有一些新聞是說
這個
大戶在開盤前
試搓鎖
漲停
騙散戶進去買
然後再到貨
講的好像就是說
欸
他
這個
試搓鎖
漲停
不用錢
然後最後幾秒再抽單
然後騙大家
但其實
當天的實際情況
就
就不是這樣
當天實際情況是
大戶用真金白銀
撐了15分鐘
甚至到
這個
開盤前
這個時候
8.59
的時候
他還在打了
500口的
多單
又
又讓
開盤前幾秒的
價錢是
回到了
所以
大戶是用真金白銀
這個
強硬的想要讓
開盤開到169
那
當天實際上是延後開盤啦
就是
呃
我印象中
這個
現貨是開在
顯示出來的數字是在
164左右
然後
就
期貨就馬上爆點
而且期貨跟現貨也有太大的價差
然後
當時
就是
變成一個
延後開盤
應該是延後兩分鐘開盤吧
然後後來是開在
呃
的地方
然後
我印象中是從
走到
高點的
然後就
就一路跌下去
163.5
對
開在
喔
開在160.5
然後
往上幾分鐘到163.5
之後就一路往下風跌
跌到最後的
打到跌停價
這樣
好
反正就是
這個
新聞講的那個其實不太正確啦
大戶當時
在開盤前
是真的花了非常多的錢
去想要
試著
幹一件大事
直接讓現貨
這個開在169
那
當時
當時也
這個
應該除了我也很多人
有撿到
撿到這一筆錢
好
那
這就是
我
這一個
一筆單
賺
54萬的一些操作想法
那
大家有什麼
問題
或有什麼想聽的
也可以再跟我說
就这样啊,大家拜拜!